but you guys know this movies coming out
don't worry neither did anyone else
I watched it so let's review it collide
so collide is directed by Jimmy honestly
I don't know who directed this movie but
it starts Nicholas Holton's Felicity
Jones Nicholas Hoult is ultimately a
reformed cars be used to work for a
really shady crime will not quite boss
like crime middle guy played by Ben
Kingsley then he meets Felicity Jones
they form a relationship he's out he's
no longer in that life for crimes and
Felicity Jones needs a kidney transplant
he doesn't have the money through his
like alright I'll do another job for Ben
Kingsley his job goes wrong and now the
tangled web of crime and what is
supposed to be a fun stylistic crime
thriller thing but let's get this out of
the way right now this really is not
good it's not good it's not great it's
completely unfocused this movie doesn't
know what it wants to focus on it
doesn't know what it wants to be
it's totally unbalanced plot wise end
characters football I like Ben Kingsley
I'm gonna get that out of the way right
now Ben Kingsley's character completely
who her she's really super shading and
really eccentric and Ben Kingsley plays
those weird characters well and I feel
like he works for the middle man that he
actually is Anthony Hopkins in the movie
though Anthony Hopkins is the unbalanced
one because Anthony Hopkins would have
been great as the really stoic scary
businessmen that will wipe out your
entire family without batting an eye she
is for half of his performance and the
other half he's kind of like a Ben
Kingsley ripoff he's also kind of an
eccentric crazy mob boss and he
shouldn't be that not only is it
completely different than his other half
of his persona but you already have that
you already have the crazy eccentric old
dude in the movie why do you need
another one works for Ben Kingsley's
character not so much Anthony Hopkins
care and for staying on Anthony Hopkins
character for a little bit it always
irritates me when these head crime
bosses go out there and get their hands
dirty they wouldn't do that
that's how crime bosses don't get caught
is they don't have their heads dirty
other they're not out there killing
people they have goons that are there
for that your goons will take care of it
use your goons while and he kind of does
until Anthony Hopkins goes out there and
shoots people you're like life why are
you doing that you set yourself up to
fail man you're setting yourself up to
get caught we're living a tech a lot
a wonderland of cameras and cellphones
meant you are one step away from rotting
behind bars forever
it's basically what this movie is it's
like it does stylist to [ __ ] because the
person who made the movie thought it
would be cool to do that but really it
makes no sense if you use any logic or
reason while watching this movie the
movies just going to unravel and fall
apart if you want to stop your brain
from doing that I feel like you can
watch this movie and enjoy again if you
start using your brain is going to fall
apart I'm not saying you should or
should not do that I'm saying that's the
information do is it what you will like
the movie if you want to but now you
know how you have to watch the movie
there are some pretty sweet car chases
in this movie though I will give the
movie that car chases and hits a couple
times of Carl's hit a concrete something
flip over itself and smash into
something else alike or others actually
really entertaining way more
entertaining than this movie is actually
setting up the big and so many times Oh
many tight this is the part when I said
if you use your brain move you're gonna
unravel moments like this so many times
Nicholas Hoult is being shot at while
he's in a car or he's on foot running
I'm like that dude is dead he is Swiss
cheese he'll see may through not a
scratch on a couple of times I was like
these cars have bulletproof glass that's
how he's living through this right up in
the glass shatter sure like I meant no
not bulletproof glass dude is just
dodging bullets by sitting there in a
car amazing guys and Ian collide is
absurd and there's a part of me that
says there's enjoyment to be had in this
movie whether it be Ben Kingsley's
eccentric performance or the fun chases
that happen in the movie this is
everything else built around the movies
not so good I was going to say this
movie's a good time if you're drunk
because of that but then I started
thinking about it I was like I feel like
if you drink and then watch this movie
you're just going to get bored and fall
away so I gotta say collide you're not
gonna remember this one in t-minus one
day yep or deeper guys all right guys
you're not going to see collide let's be
honest there so I'll ask you what's a
surprisingly good crime movie or heist
movie is that what's going to suck but
you actually enjoyed whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]